we are moving into a very dangerous
territory where we value work and we
value the coin over relationships we are
willing to sacrifice
our personal relationships being with
each other sending okay we want to send
our kids to private school but at what
cost
so that that is my question to you all
is like uh
tickets okay you're a CPA you do very
well for yourself I'm assuming right
things that life's good right you're
sending your kids to private school
you're living in Jupiter uh Abacoa I
know it very well how in your
relationship I assume you have your your
provider your protector but you're also
very present with your wife how does it
work does she ever complaining you work
too much or she's like sure honey you're
crushing it you're [__] going I love
what I'm doing in life you know what
Ebbs so when we started out she made
more money than I did actually
relationship so she used to be a
recruiter for a biotech company so she
recruited scientists over from the Dark
Side to the dark side of sales basically
and I was kind of figuring out what I
wanted to do with my life and then I
found it and then eventually you know
once we had
um kind of when she got pregnant with
our second with our son is when she
decided to become a full-time mom and
now she gets to she teaches yoga for
private parties and and that's kind of
what she gets to do and then also as as
a mom which it's it's not earning your
income but it's working it's it's
definitely working so
um so and at the same time it goes in
Ebbs and flows I think that
at when you own a business you're always
on and so there's definitely times when
she's like hey you know put your phone
down uh but then there's there's also
times we were just talking about this
where at least a couple times a year we
take five six days and go away just the
two of us and we don't do anything and
we just finished we were just in you
know just in the keys our kids went to
snorkel camp for like Monday to Friday
nine to four we got a full day every day
just to be the two of us and our
anniversary in September her parents
flew out and we had four nights at a
hotel and we just like literally laid on
the beach and did nothing and hung out
so so I think it's in order to sort of
have both it's got to be periods of
intense Focus where you are a little
distracted and maybe not connected but
as long as your balance it's not
balanced it's balancing and you're going
back and forth and taking that time to
be present and like we try to wake up
before our kids our daughter my daughter
wakes up super early so we try to get
that coffee time but and then you know
occasionally you know we'll put the kids
to bed and then we hang out together for
a little bit afterwards uh or lunch
dates are a big thing when the kids are
at school
um and so we try to you know sneak it in
but it's definitely a period of time
where it's I'm distracted and doing work
you know working hard especially during
certain busy seasons and then taking
time to just totally disconnect and and
do that too I think that's the perfect
world if we're being really honest I
think having a man that is like that
that can be successful that can be
present unfortunately I don't know
sometimes you can't have that it's work
oh it takes work it takes intention yeah
just like you know if you're this if you
you know climb up the ladder and then
it's on the wrong wall you know then
you're at the top of the ladder but it's
the wrong wall I think it's it's
critical to do that with your life and
figure out what you want we've it's been
a you know working process over you know
a decade plus of figuring out what works
and what doesn't so I also think
um it's a matter of also like you know
it's important that you have certain
values and things but what if you can't
afford the things that you value you
know like you're living a lifestyle
where you're able to uh take a vacation
with your wife and send your kids to
those places like people who make no
money don't get to do that people who
make no money they have to be at home
they have to wake up early they have to
work their butt off they're living
paycheck to paycheck like they don't
have options and I think a lot of the
time especially today it's kind of
frowned upon that women may consider you
know the amount of money a man makes
before they make a decision to date them
and be with them it was frowned upon it
it's kind of a shame because I think as
a woman you also want to consider like
your family your kids your husband the
lifestyle you want to have for them like
that also takes money and I think
sometimes we just think like oh money
materialistic things that's what goes
together but a lot of times we forget
money gives you options money gives you
the opportunity to look in different
areas money gives you the opportunity to
send your kids to private school and of
course that's going to take sacrifice
and time but again it takes effort to
also keep your relationship any family
if you have money or no money like it
takes that effort and time is going to
be distracted and pulled away but I
think in a perfect world women are like
you know we just care about the man and
of course you want to have good values
and and have those things about a man
but I think you also want to especially
today with how expensive things are that
should be something important you know
you want to consider how much is person
making how much am I making what
sacrifices need to be made to live the
lifestyle we both want but think about
if your wife judged you like that when
she first met you and think my god
parents have been married for 40 plus
years and they tell me stories about
burning chili and you know my god mother
being in tears because that was the only
you know money they had to buy the beans
for that week he's a very successful
lawyer they retired on a golf course
they're part of an amazing community in
Phoenix think about if my godmother was
like no thanks
like I said when we started she was
making making more money than I was so I
think with that it's more about earning
potential and ambition and what are you
talking about when you're talking about
how you want your life to look and when
we were having those conversations early
in our relationship when I was still in
grad school and and she was working and
going to school at night
you know we had big conversations about
building big cool things together Tyler
is your wife still working I she she's
has does teaches yoga a couple times a
week but primarily
she's no longer The Breadwinner right
okay so something's changed in the last
decade yeah where she went from The
Breadwinner and you were just kind of
starting off future career and now
you're the breadwinner yeah okay gotcha
she was an investor
it's funny how that works because if
your wife was still The Breadwinner and
you were still figuring it out oh yeah
that would be a bunny she would have cut
your ass off for 10 years yeah no
offense yeah like but the fact that you
figured it out you've made money yeah
and now she's teaching yoga even though
she was the breadwinner a decade ago
that's this that's the mortality right
there what's really cool so we we she
quit her job when she was pregnant with
our second and what was really
interesting about that is the moment she
did that
my income went up significantly
because why is that I think I think
number one is actually like oh [__] I
got some kids to take care of right but
number two when you're both working
full-time and you have children it is
everyone's burnt out everyone's
exhausted and at each other's throats
when one person can focus on raising the
family and yeah I try to be a great dad
too but like running the family is a
full-time job so then also doing a
full-time job on top of that everyone's
burnt out in that scenario so we got to
sort of take the pressure cooker valve
open the valve a little bit on that so I
could then focus on growing my business
without feeling guilty about it and then
she got to be with with her children you
know with our children and and and do
that so partnership yeah exactly if you
were in a company yeah your CEO she's
the CEO exactly is your husband partners
with you in your business uh no my
husband has his own family successful
business and they've been at it for 40
years
does he make the majority of it all of
it right now he makes all of it so if
you like that clip click right here to
watch another or if you want to watch
the entire saucecast click right here
foreign